that you are dismantling the diversity
industry and from my perspective that is
an unquestioned good because I just see
it as a new form of racism that's been
allowed to to be perpetuated on the
British and American institutions for
far too long but for people who are
perhaps you know less initiated in the
culture war in all of this what what is
the difference between
you know in America you guys always
celebrate oh this person is the first
Italian American to do this or this
person is the first African-American to
do that and that was never really a
thing that was discriminatory it was a
celebratory way of doing things but
we've kind of got way past that towards
affirmative action which openly
discriminated against certain people and
stuff like that so why is getting rid of
the diversity hierarchy a good thing
well in public universities it's an
especially crucial question so
um look I think most Americans if not
the you know the vast majority of
Americans uh want people from all
backgrounds to succeed that's part of
our national Mythos that this is a place
where you can come with nothing and you
can succeed
um you know with you know debate about
immigration and and Etc set aside for
their time being that's a core part of
the American story
um and and so but when you look at
universities you have to ask the
question what is the university for what
is the purpose I think that the
university is to pursue truth
um to to to pursue uh to to rather to
produce knowledge uh and to serve as a
community of Scholars from a variety of
viewpoints that together through the
process of reasoning and debate uh and
and and constructive criticism Can Can
it can reveal or can touch or can arrive
at those great transcendentals the true
the good and the Beautiful
um so you have you know of course uh
philosophy ethics and Aesthetics or art
um those are the kind of three uh
channels that we can create
um you know truth and beauty and so
Dei bureaucracies in practice are are
antithetical to those Pursuits Dei
bureaucracies enforce Orthodoxy you know
I've exposed public universities that
are literally telling people these are
words that you can use these are words
that you can't use you shouldn't say men
and women you should say people and
people kind you know you shouldn't say
black and white you should say you know
something else I mean it's like down to
the minute management of language by
bureaucracy
and so I think that it stifles open
discourse it stifles a free debate it
stifles even the basic process of
learning it also then serves as a racial
spoils system they have hiring and
admissions based on your on your
ancestry rather than your academic
capability they're rewarding people and
punishing People based on what their
parents uh you know what their who their
parents are uh where where their
ancestors came from and I think that is
really deeply destructive and especially
undermines the concept of meritocracy
and so in the American context you know
of course you know what Jefferson
thought of as having a a natural
aristocracy of talent and of course
wasn't fully implemented during his
lifetime obviously but we've moved uh
toward that toward that goal more and
more and I think that the Dei
bureaucracy undermines uh that as well
and then as a third component what the
Dem bureaucracy does is it manages the
university and transforms it away from
the pursuit of the the transcendentals
and toward the pursuit of current day
political activism I mean it's training
programs it's student programs it's
faculty programs they want to turn
universities away from the pursuit of
knowledge and towards the pursuit of
ideology and the pursuit of partisan
activism that betrays the fundamental
mission of the universities and I think
it portrays really the scam that the Dei
bureaucracy is it operates in these very
nice buzzwords but in practice I think
destroys the very heart of liberal
education
foreign